your next opportunity to cast your
ballot will of course be election day
tomorrow more than 100 locations will be
open
joe mohler is live at election
headquarters near cheyenne avenue
just off mlk boulevard with what you can
expect
joe well hundreds of people came here to
the clark county election center to cast
their ballot today a short time ago
there was lines of cars here but they
stopped expecting ballots around 5 30.
now come tomorrow thousands more will
cast their ballot
i believe in uh showing up to vote
with hours to go until election day
hundreds of people dropped off ballots
at the election headquarters monday
i feel good about it i feel good about
it feel like things are going to happen
real good today a change is coming
come election day there will be 125
voting locations around clark county
they'll be open bright and early at 7
and close at 7 pm
you can vote as long as you are in line
before 7 pm
every way you're going to vote that's
fine but show up and vote
and the fact that i see how many people
here just warms my heart
so far 1.1 million people have cast
their ballots in nevada
if you have not registered it is not too
late you can register in person
same day but there are documents you
must take such as an id that matches
your current address
total turnout looks like it's going to
be the highest this year that we've seen
in many many election cycles unlv
assistant professor of political science
ken miller expects a busy day tomorrow
he believes there will be people turning
out to register same day
both parties have been focused on this
so there will be some effect there i
mean we've already seen
that interest in this election is
extremely high so i'd be surprised if we
didn't see
you know any new voters showing up if
you have your ballots you can still drop
it off in person come election day
if you want to mail it it must be
postmarked by november 3rd
now if you want to see that same day
registration requirement information or
you want to see the map of the different
polling locations we do have that all up
on our website eightnewsnow.com
reporting live in north las vegas joe
mohler 8 news now